welcome to podcast ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by blue apron blue apron is the number
one fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking cooking accessible to everybody
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chefs this
is what I'm gonna do for your blue apron
it's treating the Church of what's
happened now families toward $30 off
your first order if you visit blue apron
doc Tom's last your again check out this
week's menu and get your $30 off with
free shipping at blue apron com slash
Joey blue apron a better place a better
way to cook number two listen the year
starting off I'm sure you've got what do
you call those things that you make
everybody makes those things resolutions
resolutions number one resolution on
your [ __ ] list which should be I'm
gonna keep my [ __ ] clean this year
just in case a chick falls out of a
[ __ ] bush rips my pants off and
sticks a tongue of my ass that might
happen that might not happen but just in
case that's why you gotta have a hello
douchey portable birthday where I leave
the house without bidet in that [ __ ]
muffler of yours which smells like billy
goat juice and [ __ ] Hoboken the 50s
do you need that smell in your [ __ ]
no you don't go - hello - she calm right
now and take a look at the finest
portable bird days in the market with a
90 day guarantee why waste your [ __ ]
time wiping your ass with toilet paper
aggravating that same [ __ ] hemorrhoid
you've been aggravated for the last 18
[ __ ] years throw toilet paper way save
the trees hello - she calm right now
impressing church and get 10% off your
first order why walk around with a dirty
[ __ ] when you can have a portable day
you can even take it with you to go you
can just go from place to place
put the bidet on take a [ __ ] and sit
there for two hours and let that water
creep into your muffler and take one of
the [ __ ] stomach juice out of there
good go - hello - she's calm right now
pressing church
your home but they delivered at the crib
take that [ __ ] muley [ __ ]
tremendous I'm ready to jump out a
window when I hear that [ __ ] song
that was an album that we couldn't have
in our house my mom was real religious
Catholic saints and hell plus the stab
and Judas Priest forget it how to keep
that [ __ ] out I had that album in the
[ __ ] house nobody [ __ ] kid I just
imposed my satanic will on those
[ __ ]
yeah why you no no no I like the sound
well no I like this yeah well it wasn't
red hot white he yeah the production
wasn't great those albums in the 70s you
know when they when the live album the
when they put the live album out the
[ __ ] sounded so much better Foghat live
phenomenal phenomenal
Judas Priest unleashed in the ISA Nam
Ted Nugent double I've gone some are
UFOs strangers in the night the best you
know enemy so all those live albums then
Peter Frampton Comes Alive they just
sounded better I don't know think they
can get the the right sound or something
but that did not that album sounded
shitty in the 70s but it just for some
reason really kinda dirty which one that
stained clay oh yeah I know yeah and I
kind of like it yeah that ac/dc uh let
there be rock [ __ ] dirty out yeah oh
yeah Power Rangers half dirty but right
let there be rock I think they wanted to
be [ __ ] it that was one out if you
want blood you got it wasn't in sound
that much different than the record
right that wasn't like a classic live
album no no but yeah right so yeah it's
a you know you don't want to go like the
jack the live song is back because the
dirty lyrics step on had different
lyrics for the live version about a
chick giving him clap but mother no Nana
it's not a great live album most of
those little seventies live albums were
[ __ ] phenomenon who knew new young
the Crazy Horse what was it live
something like that yeah wasn't a would
they adjust the vocals for that or what
they it would it just be like whatever
they sang live is what you got on an
album I don't know what was Skinner one
more for the road I mean that was a
double live album phenomenal them I
don't know how they did I read something
in the key
- Richards book well he said that they
forgot how to wire how to do those
things that's why you don't hear live
music anymore they forgot how to
actually technology got too ahead of
itself probably and they can't something
weird if you read his book I think
towards the end there was a pretty
really good explanation on what was
going on I thought it was just an old
guy like me talking [ __ ] about you know
society today but it makes sense they
wired everything different they might
that's the word I'm using for they might
the definite they might differently and
these guys did to cross over never
really you know never really I don't
know because my by the time the 80s came
out no one really care about live
records for me when a lot a band put at
a live record on my can whatever it
didn't sound that much different than
you know am iron made live after death
motor had no sleep til Hammersmith and
Black Sabbath live evil speak at a devil
was great because that was oz he doing
the old Black Sabbath songs and Rudy
played on their Lady Emre you know I was
in the Palladium two nights to play Deus
Christ that that was a long I'm having
that like cassette yeah
in the house he had that [ __ ] don't like
yellow coming IRAs more like that re did
I have a cassette yeah I probably have a
cassette to that because he had some
blue purple like Jam coming out of his
mouth up in his mouth I used to go to
the Palladium to disco dance back in the
day we only need to my friends would go
over and I go over there with them then
when they they turn them into Club MTV
and I was like that's it what happened
but I was living in Snowmass reading the
[ __ ] housing covered alive
speak of the devil whatever that double
album and when I saw her playing it like
what are you talking about but in those
days those clubs double been tripled
because I went to see two b-52s I'd like
to R it's like an eighty one eighty
right that's when those bars were like
during the week there was something else
long [ __ ] time ago a long time ago
yeah they just did like two shows there
you know what happened was at Sheridan
and
- a few - a Black Sabbath at the time
you know when Ronnie was with the band
and they had the two different bands
going out Black Sabbath and Ozzy solo
and they caught wind that Black Sabbath
was doing the live evil record and we're
gonna put a live album out so Sharon
goes you know it [ __ ] them let's put
an album out live album out before them
so they had like two weeks to record an
album and did all whole Black Sabbath
songs and Randy didn't wanna do those
songs Randy Rhoads was still in the band
alive at a time he's like I don't want
to I'm ready playing like three Black
Sabbath songs live Rudy tells the story
in his book he's like I don't want to
play old Black Sabbath songs on a record
he almost quit the band over it
him and I was he had a big falling out
over it and remember and he's like fine
I'm gonna do and I got one more album
after this and then I'm gonna leave the
band
but he didn't wanted to but they rush
that album out they wanted to get it out
before the Black Sabbath live about
live-evil album and that's the only
reason they never did any of those songs
like live the wizard and all that stuff
they never do a solo never did that but
they just said that the [ __ ] Sabbath
before whatever live album was coming
out and how you remember this stuff is
it's it's I know there's no reason I
should remember that now I do the same
thing it's don't forget I was dating
this girl
it had to be 1986 she's young I'm young
and what a parents house and a bunch of
family people they have bought your
neighbors I'm the only one from Jersey
there and had been there like once or
twice before and just one time I'm then
the dad thought he was jolly intelligent
he was from like [ __ ] somehow whole
New York he moved to Colorado got a pair
glasses thought of reasons about they
also he's [ __ ] jolly intelligent and
I said someone hey guys you know what
man you'd have a [ __ ] great mind to
retain useful useless information and I
was like I know that like now I didn't
know where there was a compliment or a
[ __ ] I like all that trivia [ __ ] - a
lot of people don't I don't like it too
much there's some people go a little
[ __ ] overboard with it that's too
crazy for me I like to keep it light and
I'm gonna know what his dog's name is
it's like in that movie with Marky
Wahlberg or he sees the guy from
Bosley Judas Priest guitar playing yeah
rock star yeah he's like I sent you a
card with your dog do you [ __ ]
kidding me yeah you know there's people
that are that nice that you open up the
condom wind up with what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you go get a life but there's
people that are that nice that people
think juries like me I can't comprehend
since I'm like if somebody's too [ __ ]
nice I can't take it like there's some
Americans are really just that nice and
guys like me I can't understand hey
there DMO suck my dick kind of yeah and
just something your apps there's always
something I'm saying there's some people
were nice you can see they got edge to
them
I don't mind those people cuz I know
they have like [ __ ] the faults but
then there's people are just perfect ten
nice people they always want to help you
move you can admit yeah I'll bring the
truck I'll pay for you come on knock it
off hey just to nice but you're waiting
for the [ __ ] left hand to come but
the left hand never comes so you always
make a bad judgment ball and then you
feel like you get it now you always
favor [ __ ] dick well then oil so you
gotta you feel like you all my favor now
I don't mind doing that I don't mind
that's that's part of the given go it's
boiling yeah having friends you know I
can't help you [ __ ] move
you're in no danger in fine I'll give
you a ride to the airport
come on with some weed on your movie
something sit down I can I gonna live
couches to [ __ ] stories I can't do
that no more you know you Joe you were
talking earlier you brought up like you
went and like went into disco dance can
you like talk about it we've never
talked about that I wasn't this go
anymore it's not like the thing with the
hair no no no no no it was like [ __ ]
like radio music like a so it wasn't
like you're anything no no no no no no
I would never salsa dance in the public
eye which I just saw and I was at this
club up in Albany in the helic salsa
dance Friday night like Latin night and
it was like it was like a porno on the
dance floor I'm like they're all farts
like they were all [ __ ] is I'm
welcomed by them like this isn't so bad
you know like just a regular [ __ ]
white guys dance and you know you're
three feet away from the girl but these
are always white they were all moving go
into a [ __ ] spook party every weekend
I like hang out where the [ __ ]
announcements come up like I go to the
Spanish bakery in Jersey if I was a
white dude I'd be getting top not
Spanish [ __ ] every week I was a white
dude you walk into those things no habla
the grandmother pulls over fix his job
gives you a plate next thing you know
some chick sucking your dick talking in
Spanish talking about visas and
paperwork you're already on the boat
you're really on it she gave you a dick
sucking that was tremendous from a chick
that had a hunger no no it's just an eye
you know he's chicks with hunger she
wants a docker card she wants to be back
on the dream list you know you know no
it's like you know I lived on burgle on
Avenue for a long time in Union City New
Jersey and West New York and stuff and I
was like the gringo I was to what they
little white dude I was 6 1 walking on
the street I was like Brad Pitt they
loved it they loved it and then my
Spanish girlfriend one day out of the
blue she just decides to eat my ass and
I'm like what's going on I go where
where did that come how did you get to
it was like a [ __ ] into like how did
yeah she was giving me a [ __ ] and
then she just [ __ ] lifted my little
my legs up like she was changing my
[ __ ] diaper and she started eat my
ass and I'm afterwards on my butt she
goes all my friend Nino she's Spanish
who she goes she said you know you gotta
eat the guy's ass you got to eat his ass
know how to pay the rent he said oh
right in there I know how do you come
home and give him the rent money man I
told my buddy my buddy came to town and
he hooked up with a friend that said you
know heat acid he goes I told the next
day hooked up but because she might
that's the first thing she did was my
ass she would pick up your nuts I just
took that stuff it was amazing and she
was in there like everything I was like
this is called a phenomenal every time
they suck your dick there's always a
ball sucking that leads to two legs to
the muffler just to make it completely
so there's no complaints you got a
[ __ ] from a Spanish woman in the
morning forget about it
that's an a seat and a ball-sucking they
SWA the whole [ __ ] getting to moving
that's not good in the morning you've
been sweating all money this was a sweat
about your buttock yeah they came from
one of those [ __ ] countries and the
[ __ ] Trump won't even [ __ ] got a
postcard from and they don't give a [ __ ]
you have usually you can't imagine how
hot Spanish woman I can't imagine
someone picking my legs up and like yeah
oh yeah how would freak out I'll do the
trombone really your ass and whack your
nutsack from the front yeah while the GU
pick it down like a sugar cane I had a
panic attack when I had a girlfriend
spit when was you doing a [ __ ] two
o'clock I just started laughing I never
understood that you spit my digging spin
in your face ha ha ha your mom don't
spit on my dick that's the stuff I don't
either I that's disgust I don't get what
the whole thing of it is spitting on my
dick
I'll spit in your mouth don't spend my
day that's what straight some DNA let's
get one of my dick my dick didn't do
anything that you know spit this face
like he's a racist spit on me tomorrow I
don't call that was a prude I mean I am
a prude I guess some a little bit but
the hold like for years I've been
thinking I messed up to her and that I'm
like that's what everyone wants but no I
I was I mean I always started laughing
and I made her stop like please all
right why did he spit on my dick would
you let a girl at your ass I don't think
so
I realize oh yeah what if we just come
into a bubble bath yeah maybe but what
you just gave just showered like it's
like that's definitely part of it like
don't worry about this of about my smell
listen if they're not worried about what
if they go for yes holy they're not
worried for you [ __ ] they don't put a
gas mask on Oh obviously they over they
took a chance before they know what to
get ourselves in though you know what I
mean
listen I'm like don't worry about them
worry by yourself just always have you
[ __ ] tip top Magoo
and you'll never sweat that I'm only
like four or five years into like not
being weirded out by like kissing a girl
after a [ __ ] like that's like just
like this wrong
what with they're coming them now in the
make up with them yeah I make out
yeah if it's your girlfriend soon as you
shoot that pepper loading their mom
you tell her come here let me make out
and you switch that sperm and their mom
they go [ __ ] and that's what they got
mad about it's called like snowball
that's how you do if you swallows it all
the way down then you can make out water
I mean she's you know she's a good sport
for doing it one of you every day from
now how could he how could you say no to
hummus or
[ __ ] whatever green beans but you uh
I'm not gonna swirl it around so if your
girl swallows swallows at all yeah that
you won't make out or a minute later no
that's different but yeah when when do
you feel weirded out it well they're
still coming her mouth what is she doing
what is she gargling with it no I don't
know it's never come up before but
apparently Joey just goes right down
there that's a lie Leon I say yeah
you're young you just still do that [ __ ]
we shared bonds you're young you could
still do that type of creepy [ __ ] I'm an
old man nobody wants to swaps [ __ ]
sperm Joey's always been at parties
where there's been two pounds of coke on
the table so so some [ __ ] like that's
gonna go down strippers five six in the
morning up all nights and stuff like
that's gonna go down along this party's
it's [ __ ] crazy that cocaine disgust
world is another [ __ ] that's
discourage just [ __ ] freaks me
I always avoided it man I was always a
and a lot of parties a lot of hot chicks
a lot of strippers they had to coke out
and I just and always avoided it I get
called a [ __ ] I'm not gonna hook up
with you you [ __ ] baby what why not
tell you oh yeah absolutely I give you
[ __ ] cuz they want you to do it too but
a coke rockin your mom is sucking my
dick you get the full effect when I got
a skin [ __ ] rash we kiss I get some
Colombian skin rash well the jungles of
[ __ ] Panama or something cuz I always
knew my friends couldn't get a hard-on
when they
when they were doing coke so I got I got
too hot strippers here I'm not gonna
risk that well there's two thoughts of
that think of Leon Suarez is look on
Leon soir as a guy in [ __ ] Germany a
Spanish dude that Gamble's and he's a
dirty animal he's always on Twitter he's
little know at the line he knows you do
three book you do three bumps of coke
but you get them coke down with that
suck your dick for two hours so you
really don't give a [ __ ] of you that
dick gets hard you just take the dick
sucking and tell them it is and eat
their ass and eat their [ __ ] and spank
them the whole time nothing happens the
next day they got a swollen jaw they
just walk around like you broke my jaw
last night I sucked a dick for two hours
after happen you weren't complaining
what you were doing and snoring that
[ __ ] coke were you or what happens
you get two girls naked they both want
to [ __ ] and they want a threesome and
then you can't get a hard-on
I do you got to pace the room and
[ __ ] put a you got to put like one of
those army stilts like when you get it
hard you gotta tied up the bottom with
the blood on the top I don't [ __ ]
know I I mean it was I have had many of
embarrassing nights with that [ __ ] but
some way we made it work because girls
like to talk that's why you always well
that was another thing like if I wasn't
doing coke right they won't they all are
crazy sane it's like we don't drink
alcohol so when somebody's drunk my last
[ __ ] neck is standing on my I
remember telling my head this girl I
used to date I go look I go she's like
you were being mean last night I got
luck you guys were [ __ ] saying the
same thing over and over again I know
next time I'm gonna record you guys but
when you're on coke talking and we're
gonna listen or in the morning and you
tell me who was [ __ ] right no it was
wrong it's a horror show
it's brutal you only want to do it just
so you can fit in because you can't take
it sober or even just a few beers I sit
there you don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking I would go any other you
know I play hard-to-get I go in the
other room like a hey I'm gonna go watch
SportsCenter like no no hang out what I
said go look you guys just do your thing
talk or whatever I go just to be hanging
I'm just gonna go so and then they feel
like oh he needs attention sedate Hank
like ten minutes they get jealous that I
was kind of like blowing them off and
then they would come in the room and I'd
[ __ ] bolt it was great
what a weird [ __ ] lifestyle but
that's what you had to do yeah yeah you
had a trick them yeah you have to trick
people but I didn't want to I didn't
want to do coke I never did it before I
I see my I saw my friends on it we'd all
you know we go to the bar every Friday
and Saturday night go try to pick up
girls and we get to start drinking like
6 o'clock soon as we got off of work
drink to about 10:00 10:30 we're all
getting in it too early you're never
gonna pull one out that early you're not
pulling one out of 9:30 in a [ __ ]
dance club there's no [ __ ] way they
just got there they need some drinks in
them so we get there around 10:30 11:00
to close at 1:30 so they've got a nice
buzz on you ought to buy them drinks
then we get one guy would pay and they
get us we get a black stamp and then we
could walk you know I forgot something
my car and I go back out what a stamp is
still wet and press it on like nine
other guys hand so we'd all get him with
one price I remember when the beach had
the the thing on your hand down in
Lavallette in seaside when we were kids
they stamp yeah and then you went up to
the thing and there was like a
glow-in-the-dark like a purple yeah why
the seaside park yeah yeah yeah one of
them I'll never forget one time I went
on one of those things and it was like
six gorillas going onto the beach and
there's like an old guy you had to be
like [ __ ] 18 hey telling guys I me
and my friends walked it on and we all
get in there and like the fourth guess
like the shark ate it and he can't walk
in because of him
but won't take you to write this [ __ ]
book I only got a couple excerpts I
didn't get the book but I read like ten
pages and I kept reading because it was
interesting but then my daughter came in
the room and said you gotta put on Coco
and then we never said yeah yeah I get
it no I did you know uh three years it
took me reuse yeah well you know what
also it's based on my podcast basically
I just rant about different like social
media [ __ ] bad Facebook posts and stuff
like that and then uh I started you know
I transcribed all month these podcasts
and then I cut it down you know I
transcribe and then I cut it down I sent
it to a book at it and we worked on it
together but it's been three years in
the making it's crazy how well you were
talking about Facebook and I felt what
you were talking about every level
it's weird that when regular people read
that book like the progressive people
they're gonna read what I read and go
he's so wrong he saw because they don't
get it like nobody would get now you
really wrote about the likes and what
before I got on Twitter to Facebook I
was on Rogen's podcast one day and I
wanted a rant about you know why would I
want to be on that tonight your [ __ ]
friends you know I have like 700 friends
at the time and I was talking about that
how stupid is I wouldn't go on Twitter
in those days I just had a Facebook and
to when it was just starting to pick up
steam I'm like I don't [ __ ] know you
know myspace was the biggest thing since
Jesus and that dropped like a [ __ ]
awesome myspace had AIDS yeah he was the
wise now he's no more it's still there
it's still there but nobody goes so I'm
gonna forget going on Twitter than
saying that and I have a like part like
I've met a lot of great people through
social media to shows you know but when
you look at some people in particular
and look what they're doing like I
follow people on Facebook just to read
how ridiculous they're like they're on
this side and I'll click them less they
have like seven postings I'll click
through them just a [ __ ] laugh but at
the same time a part of me feels bad for
them because they're part of that world
even in real life where they're
surrounded by people that just tell them
everything's amazing that they do do you
know I'm saying yeah and while I was
reading what you wrote about that I was
thinking of this particular person
because there's two people I follow on
Facebook I would never drop their name
because I can't believe somebody's this
[ __ ] stupid
there's two people I follow on Facebook
because they're so [ __ ] stupid
I've never seen anything like that
how often do you check in on them every
two or three days like I'll leave
tomorrow and I won't check out them till
Monday it easily because I just shake my
head one person I've known for 20 years
and has changed completely and he's
become very political but he'll call me
every [ __ ] week and tell me why he's
got no commie Korean I feel like saying
have you seen your Facebook post there's
not even done entertaining
everything is troubling you and your
[ __ ] stupid wife charm painting let's
go shoot yourself we have to stop the
[ __ ] color then there's a broad that
attacked me one day years ago and I see
the part of the world that she's
involved in comedy like this like a
couple different levels of comedy that
people really don't know about there's
the level that we do we play for keeps
this is what we do we've been doing it
for 20 years when we die we'll be on a
stage but then there's a lot of hobbyist
and then there's people have done comedy
for a long time and they go to a circle
that it's like these weird shows they do
and they all have a theme and they're
under theme is hate the corporate comic
like that you know their whole show she
had a bad experience of one of the clubs
like The Improv was something like ten
years ago and for ten years she's gone
on a rant about the club isn't how but
it's like I'm saying tear it's that
stupid but she's never really let it go
well it's pretty interesting to see then
she would just focus on the comedies for
the Laugh Factory she would've been
straight but for ten years she's been
attacking the [ __ ] and it's so weird
like where they go now what part of
clearly they belong to now they belong
now she's in a woman's comedy thing and
they they go to a woman's thing this is
woman you've never seen or heard of and
all of them have a an a hat on or an
incognito tattoo or you know it's not
really comedy and you see the comments a
way and you want to smack all those
people you want to go to that show and
smack all those people individually for
even you know
these days like it's just it's [ __ ]
that's basically what it is you're not
doing your friend that he famous I
posted that nonsense I don't know am I
getting clearly no absolute lies don't
know 100% I mean you know I don't want
to sound mean you don't like a mean
hearted person but that's what whenever
I tell Lee I'm giving that person rope
to watch them hang themselves that's
what I mean like I watch people from
time to time and I learn not what to do
on social media from watching them I get
like why you posed in that oh my god but
this is why that dude's on a cruise ship
yeah and uh you know look yeah I mean
people I really focus on now just
telling jokes on stage like I always did
but I'm like I'm just I'm just gonna
give you jokes because I feel like every
comic all of a sudden is all political
and and none of us so you look at the
timeline or on Facebook I like to write
just [ __ ] people follow you not that
you have to entertain them all the time
but at least you know nobody gives a
[ __ ] everybody else is everybody saying
the same thing as you you don't even
there's a million people doing the same
thing it's just like you're gonna get to
the point where you're not gonna know
what's funny enemy you're so angry out
of work with what's going on in politics
that you can't how are you gonna bring
that onstage and be funny like how are
you gonna even be funny it's not just
you gotta take a lot of your weapons
away like if you're worried about
everything that what everybody says you
know and you're offended by this and
this then how are you gonna go onstage
and talk about that like these girls
like you know cry over the meat too and
no less all the [ __ ] like okay so you a
lot of girls hide like rape jokes in
their act like they I get raped if the
guy was good-looking what so you can't
do those anymore so you just took all
those jokes out of your act cuz you're
all about this and you believe women and
bleeped and then you can't go onstage
and joke about rape so now all these
jokes are out here I like [ __ ] now what
am I gonna talk I can't do that I can
you know sort of did taking a lot of
weapons well I just go up there be
[ __ ] funny whatever is a joke
whatever is funny is funny you don't I
mean but when you when you side with
that then all of a sudden you're gonna
you get to me like man I've been are not
putting that up anymore [ __ ] how am I
gonna joke about that when I'm just
bitching about how awful it is you got
to believe everybody
ah [ __ ] it is you know we just live in a
weird time like that where people don't
really want to say what's in their
father and and it started about 10 years
ago but now with all the accusations and
how many people you sexually harassing
your day
I gotta go for [ __ ] mm well you know
I had 25 years of calmly you know you
meet some [ __ ] savages out there it
or just even savages hanging in the
club's easy or sound like when you you
know going to those nightclubs of coke
and beers and hanging out and hook it up
and all that stuff does it chick I
hooked up with I follow on Facebook oh
my poor mentor from time to time
hilarious hilarious that was borderline
[ __ ] sexual harassment fueled by
cocaine I just went to a house where she
was a nanny she really wasn't a nanny
she was [ __ ] the husband the husband
died and the wife had so much money she
didn't really give a [ __ ] what the
husband was doing
I've never gone over there 3:00 in the
morning to get coke from the husband he
wasn't a coke dealer he was just the
friend that he goes come over I got like
an Eightball take it and she was there
with a robe on and he's there with a
robe on watching TV like always you want
sit up first limit but this is [ __ ]
crazy
so flashback to like three months later
it's like the first week of December and
I'm gonna bar in Jersey you know where
your little neighborhood bars Motley
Crue's are looks to kill the whole
[ __ ] deal was snorting coke in that
with drinking Bluebirds vodka and
bluebird orange juice in the tin can two
hours and she comes in the girl she's
[ __ ] banging and I hadn't seen this
since that night like what the [ __ ] is
said you know what I see here he's like
45
she's my age she graduated from a high
school wonderful if I can saw in her
[ __ ] legs I didn't know was her just
a body cold oh [ __ ] nice but snort and
drink I'm falling all that so where's
Jesus you look really good too that I
kept looking
why she would [ __ ] tremendous I think
I gave her a blast of coke
she asked her if I was dueling and then
at the bar one thing led to another she
disappeared or what happened
the sitch she went home tell them to
help that dudes house i sat there with a
couple more wives the couple of
cocktails at 3:00 I walked down that gym
I knocked on that door I go can I talk
though he has to go to Rome hey hey hey
you don't what's going on amigo can I
talk about Danny she was at the bar
before my wallet disappeared can't say I
care if I'm gonna get fired okay so [ __ ]
that's tomorrow come on let's get out of
here so [ __ ] she went as I kept
soundless I must take my time here so I
can't smile I'm a sucker [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] like it nipples on five coke
watching their [ __ ] okay okay I'll
come this she opens up the back Bush
saying hold on he's sleeping I know if
we got that look on table refrigerators
at the positive back from like a
business I just took it to go she know
we got time throw this cash and then I
hide in the bathroom we got one of those
totally having the hotels yeah down
those disgusting things only great auto
motel one of us this a couple of this -
yeah arrogant does it pretty good this
one on 91st Street and this woman 70th
Street open to run no free breakfast
it's just a bar a vending machine with
potato chips and [ __ ] cinnamon buns
and [ __ ] but the one they have two rooms
in that hotel that had the star jacuzzi
yeah but I'll never forget I went to one
for a coke party and a bunch of people
and where did your cozy bother when that
could see him scratching like the herp
was on fire it was the same tub that Lee
jumped into that B&B that time well he
got the rash on his neck he came home I
got a sty I was terrible that's right
from the air B&B [ __ ] jakku
sexual harassment thing love throw us in
jail Jim that's like that [ __ ] that's
what you're doing Josh that's what you
do when you grow up in Jersey
essentially the last people nudge it's
anybody just talking about you don't
give a [ __ ] offices what are you an
idiot I don't know you smack them and
you [ __ ] say something I don't
[ __ ] know well how many times did
Gries grab girls in the bar when you're
walking by him like a nightclub you're
always doing that rubbing on although I
get too scared I mean just like yeah you
know we were younger that's he always
did that stuff if I grew up with you and
I knew you were like there was one or
two girls I played that with but at the
same time you know I didn't get out of I
never wanted for that monkey and that's
like that no I'm just saying like you
know you kind of like brush up against
their ass is too welcomed by him in a
crowded nightclub that always happened
like oh will you brush up or when you
get a picture with are you on the road
no no I'm just saying don't you think a
picture with a husband and a wife is she
got big titties yeah she takes a jacket
off and lays them on your arm and you
could feel the vein pumping from a
[ __ ] heart and hurt it and you only
what the [ __ ] is this but you can't say
nothing that sexual [ __ ] harassment
I'm saying she's giving me a [ __ ]
hard-on she's taking me into the murky
waters she's giving me false hope yeah
I've had girls grab my ass in a picture
yeah the hole that is there to where her
husband's taken at me she puts around
grab value sometimes kiss it didn't you
like what the [ __ ] guy
she's like smell it Tiffany already like
honey just show me your tits come on you
up on that favorite Yankee fan no other
mom more self society I liked okay it's
funny because when I was like in a six
[ __ ] right all right there was a
basketball game at the high school and
there's the New York Mets against North
Bergen faculty and this was like my
first year in that whole curriculum I
have lived in North Bergen but I went to
school according once I got thrown out
of that school and Carly I had to go to
North bird this is my first semester in
los perros basketball season
it's like November in the Mets
John Matlack couple Mets came over and
they played against North Bergen high
school
faculty and I went up there with these
[ __ ] gangsters from 26th Street these
little [ __ ] kids were savages there
was a project up there the North Bergen
side but if you cross the bridge it
turns into a nice residential
neighborhood flag go over that side to
play basketball you make friends with
those kids and they're a lot more fun
than we were having on that side of the
burger they will go up to you in the
city and beat kids up with socks filled
with flour
they had dura test where they used to
steal light bulbs and the dumpsters and
beat themselves up with light bulbs
belong ones you know for luck someone's
also long arrest someone they were bout
the van powder all oh yeah yeah they
these kids rock they rob things they
always had cash they were always
involved in some I knew a little Feliz
leader of this little patio in the 6th
grade so I'm going in the afternoons it
was a cute girl there was a girl one of
the first girls I haven't asked on a
date maria caba ha I just met with her
my height my 6th grade teachers Bar
North Bergen when I went home and oh man
but we still all meet the Thursday
before the Friday I play gotham's we all
meet and that teachers bought we eat
chips and [ __ ] but I stole my Maria
being in that neighborhood and I would
[ __ ] go over there and just what was
the point of the story anyone before we
started
sectional raftsmen so these guys are sad
someone that I go over they go hey dummy
and you want to go up and see the Met
game against us yeah a little cold out
nothing nothing extreme we took the
number one bus Kennedy Boulevard up to
the high school watch the game and then
with three minutes left two minutes left
all my buddies goes let's go let's get
out of here before we get caught in here
so right side hanging in front of the
high school the high schools packed and
it had to be you know like eight of us
and we will meet like six other [ __ ]
gorillas we half of us wave is sexually
developed I probably just had the hair
on the sides and then had the whole
filling right I had the bozo look yeah
yeah I was just I wasn't coming yet but
I was already whacking off I already
wanted to suck somebody's titties and
[ __ ]
and I'll never forget that there must
have been his girl if we were 12 she
must have been 15 and she came out of
the high school
what about two other girls and we were
kids and one of these guys I was with
just went up to the girl started
grabbing her tits and two guys went up
to the girl three guys went up to the
girl they have been like a rumba never
got enough that she had blown somebody
my friends didn't even want to go
through like usually you fight another
chick seconds to the dick you wait a
month and you ask her on a date you send
the flowers you helpful with homework
you get her out one night you give her a
[ __ ] half a pack and she'll suck your
dick in the car
Yap but if you attack her like an animal
she's not gonna suck your dick the word
will get around this girl must have suck
somebody's [ __ ] I don't know what
happened but next thing you know this
poor girl was coming up coming up that
her friends were just pushing guys away
and nobody was raping or ripping off her
clothes all they were doing Todd was
grabbing her tits and grabbing her ass
and grab the [ __ ] and grab her that
she's [ __ ] better that's it she was
going off and I that was one of the guys
that I grabbed the tit and then I backed
off when I saw what the [ __ ] was
happening doesn't like one of the
security guards came on everybody ran
away that was the craziest thing I ever
did as a kid but again that was 12
nobody heard that girl enough they guess
something must happen sexually she did
something these gorillas had no [ __ ]
they had no logic or whatever because
was rare back in that day at 12 years
old for a girl a blow you or a girl
[ __ ] like there was only a few of
them in the school I don't think there
was anyone in my school with 12 maybe
there was look I had a friend who
knocked somebody up in the seventh grade
one so low
I'll never forget that floor wall once
Odom got the girl pregnant quit school
never sobbing it and then the family
packed up and moved away do you begin
there was a couple kids I went to school
with that had kids in high school that's
[ __ ] scary
yeah it's always something yeah but back
to the Facebook post sorry no no it's
alright but yeah I mean you do you see
well I I like you know when people go
cuz a lot of its just attention seek and
people just looking for attention maybe
they're not getting in at home or who
knows what it is you know one's just
everyone's just trying to compete with
each other you know so someone leaves a
post like I'm on my way to the hospital
and that's it so now you're gonna have
to have like 75 car you okay what's
going on
no if I lived in New Jersey I'd meet you
there keep me posted
do you need you know Wallace stuff and
meanwhile that you it's never anything
serious finally when you read down to
the bottom about 35th comments she's
like oh it's just a sore throat but
thanks for everyone's concerns because
you know what posting that everyone's
gonna go is you know what's wrong you
know [ __ ] like that so you know that
it's all it is attention-seeking post
yeah facebook is getting weird I
actually like I don't know if you've
seen this there's people on Facebook
like who see now like like when I was
going to high school like Facebook was
just coming out so it was crazy to have
like a picture of you with a beer in
your hand right cuz you're underage now
like people are posted like people are
getting caught all the time like for
selling drugs or or going on Facebook
live and shooting people it's crazy it's
gay it's like yeah that's crazy what
people are willing to put up online
don't we do podcast and everything is
public but it's like jeez yeah you know
and look it's just if you're constantly
putting pictures up you guys partying
and you know being her party beers and
you could see some coke maybe or some
kind of weed laying around and you're
posting all these pics on your Facebook
page when you go for a job people are
gonna look for that [ __ ] oh yeah
absolutely they're gonna see this stuff
like eyes no I can't hire this person
look at this or you're all you know all
of that stuff so it's all all those
pictures are out there they are good at
it though like do you ever like I'm not
really great at social media and I think
some of these people like better social
media experts and then people who do it
professionally like the feel like these
like there's some pretty girls out there
who have like amazing social media and
they doll that they don't do anything
they just
yeah well yeah of course I mean and
they're not even getting paid for this
post every day 95% of my Instagram is
just hot chicks I just look at that look
looking at hot chicks there's a lot of
them on there but we were just saying
like it's I think it's crazy how there's
some people you're you're really good at
social media Joey but there's a lot of
people who aren't who do it
professionally
myself included and I think there's like
a lot of teenagers today who are who are
better than if I was 22 I'd be I'd be
making a half million on social media if
I was 22 and I was good-looking there
would be no stopping me especially on
Instagram all the buttons to push I love
how easy this look at what this girl did
this week Tiffany Haddish
she got Groupon to [ __ ] sign her as
their spokesman for a year if you really
wanted to do that you could do that
today it's very easy just why don't you
put an Instagram post about our Groupon
or something out that $1 she went on
Kimmel and told the group one story on
Kim la she took what Smith in his life
and his wife on a group on tour when
they were shooting a movie in New Orlean
now she has been a fan Travis fan at
Groupon fries I love Groupon myself I
love it I look on group when I'll get
anything on Groupon before I go [ __ ]
see it especially I got I got doubts
about it you know for 26 bucks another
[ __ ] a charge yeah worked if you go
down that twice and three times got the
place so she kept [ __ ] with it and
eventually and that's very attainable
today you know if you just you just
contact the company and you're hey man
is there a code I could use to again
like 10% I had to a podcast or whatever
even starting at that level and you just
keep attacking the bulb of the product
you keep attacking it you know if it's a
cup every sporting event you're gonna
bring the [ __ ] cup we eventually
you're gonna get and get momentum with
that [ __ ] thing especially if you're
doing different things at that cup if
you're just taking a picture with the
cup and you're a guy you're in no danger
but if you got a chick hung upside down
by your [ __ ] ankles and the compass
in the cleavage and the ice cubes are
fall in your mouth
I need other self some [ __ ] cops
somebody's gonna reach out to you
eventually it's being creative with that
product that's it you could brand
yourself until I with all the social
media social media has a lot of great
stuff now it definitely does it has a
lot of and I'm not saying I'm not
knocking social media but it has the
other side of that coin then it's just a
little too it's getting to some but I
still say crazy [ __ ] oh that I'm waiting
for them to throw me off I've been
suspended a couple to move but never you
know I would hate not too bad for 30
days right Ari Ari's been yeah I already
think throw anything at bread on a bird
on that but I don't use it to how other
people the social media is great to
promote yourself I remember you know
when I first got my website in the
mid-2000s it was like 600 bucks a month
where all the bandwidth I needed to play
audio and video on there I was paying
600 bucks a month and then Facebook and
all these things come around now I pay
like $100 more 50 bucks a month from 600
I'm like this is so it's basically free
to have all that [ __ ] but yeah and then
you just gotta keep up with it you gotta
keep you know but my stuff is more of
like you know the people that just uh
you know just post nonsense like there's
no reason for a post you know like you
know take a picture them you know cuz
they're out to dinner you don't I mean
like a ready to eat you know hashtag
hungry okay I you know I had a feeling
he went to a restaurant is probably
gonna be food there
you know I mean it's like you know just
dumb stuff like that it's like okay I
got a scroll through all of the [ __ ]
there's one good one I saw there was
this guy who every time he was out with
someone taking a picture like that would
smash their food right before they took
the picture and people would get
genuinely upset
sure you know the food is fine if they
were just man who they were in the
picture how we smash the food it's just
the spoon so it views our friends and
yeah okay okay I told you Matt if like I
went to your table no no the abroad that
me wrong no but yeah now you know just
and then also uh you know the vanity
license plates its fussy out in LA
they're all over the place you know
people bragging whatever they do or -
trying to be funny you know it'll be a
places plate lol okay what is that gonna
do is that gonna make somebody laugh
yeah but that was invented in New Jersey
when I was growing up what those creepy
license plates not for none nobody has
creepy license plate there's a town in
Jersey there's an Italian people when I
was growing up what are they saying
I'll just you know they always had you
know that's what that's like you listen
in New Jersey from the society I came
from there's only one thing that beats
customized license plates have to
[ __ ] you know what's the top room in
a hotel then des penthouse suite the
book Godwin Frankie Valli's in town like
that's the only thing that probably
beats that from the people I grew up
with right the debt that hysterical when
I was a kid I had two buddies who had
vanity license plate so they drove
remember what they what they said
one buddy own a funeral parlor so it was
HTV number one you know Anthony P van
airy
number one funeral parlor and he put a
guy OH
[Music]
a store his name was hatchway and he put
hash and that was a bad idea
two people up tone said you drug that
they changed it to something else
Dalli Dalli yeah that's a good one yet
deli number one right [ __ ] my people
would have those Frank you know back to
the seven like you had when I was
growing up you really hadn't know people
buy down a DMV they get personalized
why's this place like that was like a
cachet type dealing so I'm putting them
on the call and I'm going out of the
book God there was no book God at that
right there was a mouse but but I still
remember the Borgata opening and a
friend of mine calling me going don't I
just saw you hoping for Rogen at the
Borgata this had to be like four months
after it opened like really in the
beginning there was a fight down there
and that's why I was down there with a
mind stay for the fight I went up north
I left him and taint a bunch of the
savages that but I'll never forget like
a week before I was going a friend of
mine course I remember my son's going to
see virtual realm he said you're working
you're in the port god oh my god I was
down there last week it's like a dream
come true it's better than a casino in
Las Vegas I mean just went on I was so
[ __ ] excited if you're opening up my
room I like it smell Cologne from the
people when they're laid before I want
the [ __ ] is this
I can smother a [ __ ] Cologne I get
some other golf balls in my room is [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] they were doing in
there
[Music]
who the [ __ ] my husband is one thing you
don't say I'm just trying to [ __ ] him I
wish the stench I just want AC this
Sunday would you do me my buddy's got
sweets went down there watch the games
drank [ __ ] gambled went to a strip
club stayed out till 3:00 4:00 in the
morning got down there at noon both
games are all of the Sunday game
football games the NFL games are on hung
out in the bar [ __ ] putting bets in
bookies [ __ ] drinking going crazy
they're all getting high then we ended
up with a strip club how is this trip
phenomenal
dude no there was one that's all nude
but you have to bring you have to bring
your own booze in they don't sell it in
there we have to go buy it next or as a
package good store right next door to
strip club so you buy it there you bring
it over there and it's all nude the
other one was they keep that you know
bikini the g-string in the top on that's
better that was better why cuz it cuz
when it's all nude there's a lot more
rules you can't go near them they can't
come close to even more like a lap dance
you know I didn't see you after Florida
I remembered your name and I watched you
at different clubs not watch you
personally but then you did the HBO
thing it was good to see you that I knew
you were still alive and kicking and
then you used to do the show on Comedy
Central you tormenting people on the
phone I never really watched that shot
don't watch a lot of comedy sentimental
idea but reading your book you know
reading your book I know both the same
songs because we grew up in the same
area but there's a chapter you got in an
EPS on there
ever said whenever the [ __ ] I got him
saying and I rather that's you being
whatever in your room not knowing that
what you were doing was the building
blocks of your career yeah hauling
people and harassing people and I'll
never forget the first people I used to
arrest I would your over witnesses and
he owned the barber shop like two blocks
away and me and my buddy will walk past
a barber shop and like [ __ ] look at
him me he would tell us to get off the
thing and then we go to my buddy's house
and we visited the seventies and there
was no caller ID yeah there was no
star-69 and you picking up the phone
there was nothing you had no idea who
was calling you you had no idea you call
the unless cops came in the house yeah
hooked up something near a said there's
no way no way no way you used to have a
field day I mean this guy he was just
the bobble was a joke with this and the
only cut you're over witness ass so we
would go to my friend's house and just
call and say you know like that dingo
that whole wah like that means Joe
witness in Spanish he said King outline
me and then would say then we'd sing a
song 50 or they Oh theythey and we just
hang up on him we do this like 20 times
a day time that was the extreme point or
man then you did the Jersey wedding
songs of what like tormented people and
what's the vid 12 and then somebody told
me the Jersey things you know is your
refrigerator running or go catch it you
know all that [ __ ] yell out yeah go
through all those stupid phases you call
people well we had this girl in our
class in seventh grade remember me my
buddy Tony she had these huge tits so we
got her phone number
somehow I had a phonebook and we called
her up and we're like hi this is a
national survey we just want to know
what your bra size is and she's like is
this Tony and Jim you you creeps and
hung up on us that was like my first
prank call and then there was another
time we just go we dial numbers and it
was a woman answered wherever we're just
yeah we dial random numbers ago how big
your tits that's all we would say so
we're doing this all day if we get a guy
we just hang up so I'm downstairs at my
buddy Tony's house he's upstairs the
other other line on the phone and I'm
he's our YouTube you dial and I look
under refrigerant I see mom's office
number
so I his mother's office number she
works a dental assistant so I [ __ ]
call there I go Kate your turn
so his mom picks up hello Madison dental
he goes how big your tits shake is this
Tony oh my god ah god [ __ ] chase
chase me out of the house doubt like
through the neighborhood like [ __ ]
for like a mile that he yelled that to
his own mother how big your tits
he's full of calling people hanging up
on them and all that creepy [ __ ] we were
just doing that my buddy was on [ __ ]
percocets coke pot and had like nine
drinks he was out of his [ __ ] mind at
the wheel or the listen we're watching
the game watching a game he's out of his
mind he's [ __ ] all over the place so
we just keep calling his phone his cell
phone we hit star six seven first so it
just cups up no caller ID and he's like
hello hello and I'm just and I'd start
talking Michael what you put on the bed
on the game he's like why I go oh sorry
you're on the phone he goes who is this
who's calling we got him 20 times in a
row he had no Chloe goes somebody keeps
calling I've double you should pick it
up it might be important it might be a
wife he's like you're right hello and
twenty times in a row oh I love doing
[ __ ] to people and then when he goes
where's the bath and my goats right down
there just make a left over there I sent
him in the kitchen and a [ __ ] of the
bar we never tell him whatever
what's the waiters name Steve he comes
over a Steve now my name is Jeff Oh
why'd you call him Jeff it's nonstop
some guy order mozzarella sticks at the
table I get a beating for 20 minutes
what are you five you're a grown man you
learning mozzarella sticks
what's next [ __ ] you know there's a
little therapy like for all this that's
just that's your way of showing
affection oh my god you know what I mean
like okay you're bought you're part of
the CRO okay
yeah I'm like what's next grilled cheese
you want the ends cut off you want you
want to go Girt with your [ __ ]
mozzarella sticks on the side but that's
just and it's just like okay just you
just take it and you just hope it goes
to somebody else never order mozzarella
stick lien I hate [ __ ] what's ROS
things yeah you said I can't only
calamari tune this weekend nonetheless
[ __ ] you guys gonna Austin yeah I'm
taking the loss - these are like a
column or you'll say when you go back
east great barbecue down there man yeah
I was worried about the barbecue right
don't worry about the [ __ ] calamari
we're gonna pop a dose we unless you got
a mouse in your pocket you're going
right over to the barbecue place okay
soon as we land I'm putting you in uber
you want the barbecue place it - I'll
see you by 6:00 bring back some brisket
on a mission go online mingle get to
meet people in Austin Tom some stories
sound again what do you think right
Austin you know he's a young guy go
mingle you're single - right no no money
you know how will he kill him yeah
you're not standing on line take
pictures put them on Twitter picture
will do you are yourself you got a girl
fun I do no cheat your ass no no and
only in her ass it's a mutual
relationship I can't
what if she just does once a what all of
a sudden cuz that's what I am on my
Spanish girlfriend she just one day I
did a blow I don't think she's gonna win
down to the blue do that but I don't
think so man
I don't I don't think that's for me I
haven't even had anal sex like that's
I'm not as grossed out by that as I used
to be but like this story when Joey said
that story on a little podcast it was on
with the tinfoil like I can't imagine
even going near a woman's [ __ ] like
that that's just too much for me I don't
know there's this poop in there I think
I just can't
I'm sorry you believe this yeah but a
girl's gonna know you don't I mean she's
not gonna be holding in a [ __ ] and guess
what let's have anal she's gonna know
she prepares herself she's not gonna let
you go in there
well sometimes you put in the muff
and you get it going and you pull out
your little dick so just comes on it
comes on like soft serve ice will stop
it this is my kid
ya know at the same time you take him to
the cleaners why did you stick that maha
helmet in their muffler and you're
pumping at the same time you rub that
clip with your hand like a [ __ ]
machine gun and you do a double loader
I'm telling you sometimes just he's not
that so servlets in there it's like
George Washington stick in the cannon
your child like the Caddy is I've never
been involved with that I heard a
particular friend of mine took a girl
home one night and while they were
having sex she [ __ ] and just let it
all go
yeah yeah my buddy did that on his
honeymoon my 40 Tony his wife had like
they were they went down to Mexico so
she she must have drank the water and
she had diarrhea and he was [ __ ] her
in the ass and it was just all over and
he sucked [ __ ] I was on my honeymoon I
just kept going he said I wasn't gonna
stop that you would never do that like
that oh no he's a gentleman Oh Jose this
girl she came to my show I did a college
sound like Tennessee oh my god I was 19
years old I was like 25 I go to the I go
to worked at Waffle House I got no
waffles in the mornings because I was at
your comedy show last night you're
really funny I go you were in the
audience cuz yeah like okay and I was in
town for an all night I go I'm we're
talking I go we should hang out tonight
because I have to work 14 hours today I
came in at 7:00 I gotta work whatever I
go I go want to come to my I go once we
hang out later she was like I have more
I couldn't just come to my hotel room
we'll have some beers and she looks at
me like what I got I go whatever right
and then I go look I'm in room 320 you
know to holiday and she's yeah I know
where it is like I well if you can come
this would be for phones
she shows up after a 14-hour shift in a
Waffle House uniform I ate her ass 20
minutes later after a 14-hour shift so
the family that's a soldier right in
there that's a soldier 14 hours you
having a baby while there's no the
waffle is uniform on
right in there there's no hello to you
now what am I gonna have a nineteen yo I
get copper ass in my hand one [ __ ]
same let me just shout out to the next
level and my Hagin Michael s Kusum mcus
christopher deivis
Justin Stanley listen to the jungle we
dommage Nate is here Jeff Collins Jesse
Lindquist and my man
Gino PAC digital or something like that
you know I love you [ __ ] I
write this [ __ ] you know when I'm high
and I don't understand what the [ __ ] I'm
reading at the time but you know I got
you I got you I got you in my [ __ ]
mind all right am i hanging you know I
love you
she always says nice things in the
morning we had a lot of nice people
we're about to see who keep spooky can't
wait [ __ ] Thursday night Bobby
Sheeran crystal [ __ ] boyfriend Dallas
is coming down with some Cuban pastries
like oh we're getting barbecue on
Saturday night we're getting Chinese
food you're gonna get all this [ __ ] I'm
getting it I'm sorry I mean Papa those
fish and salads I gotta stick to my
little way watch your [ __ ] speaking of
writing stuff down when you're hanging
out after that party last week yeah I
had a little edible and I wasn't shot
behind do you ever go shopping hi that's
the only when I go shopping for the last
20 years I can't do it why was I always
like I always get something wrong my guy
went and looked in the fridge and I
always get something [ __ ] up always
place them to you when you're sober you
do [ __ ] this [ __ ] that's fair this point
what does it matter
at least have some fun while you're
doing it last time you were [ __ ] so
but you ended up in San Jose for many
years that was my room with disgusting
omelets disagreement together let's go
why do you torment them once you're
happy with it so the book comes out
February 20 yeah
is this your first book now yeah really
yeah oh I thought you had books before
now I know you're working on one right
you said bless someone's focus right
every day it's if it's [ __ ] it's the
toughest thing man Adil you think it
wouldn't be that tough but just the
process I'm doing an audio book to where
you got to go be in a studio for like
nine hours a day reading from it to like
four nine hour sessions which is
horrific
I like the writing process I'm enjoying
in there I'm on the roll down from when
I wake up I have an outline I know what
I'm attacking I was really a bad before
had been [ __ ] you never would you stand
up you never sit down and write like
yeah yeah but you never did before you
just kind of like when it came to you
you do kind of work it out on stage you
have an idea maybe you listen to it cuz
the theory is if you weren't good at
school if you didn't have good school
study habits
you weren't discipline like to sit down
and write like like some other comics
that were good in school like to sit
every morning and write out [ __ ] I was
never like that I'm like when it comes
to me it comes to me I'm gonna write and
I'm gonna work it out at stage I'm gonna
listen back you know and [ __ ] like that
but I was never one that I could sit
down every day at 10 o'clock and [ __ ]
and write because I wasn't good at
school I just [ __ ] did whatever I did
could to get by so I didn't have good
study habits at all I've always said
just after I got left back I'll yell at
back I got a good study habits I was
always I was always did well in school
but I discovered women in the sixth
grade
yes yeah I got sophomore year in high
school I was playing baseball I was on
the team starting and then I got into
weed drinking and girls so now was it a
quick baseball three months later
there's looking at a hustla magazine I'm
like I'm done
it's there's a whole lot of life out
there it [ __ ] me up completely it
threw me off completely just just
throw me out of my game love the whole
[ __ ] deal I haven't gone to summer
school I didn't go I would play hooky
from that and the third time they threw
me out and they said I had a [ __ ] get
left back what grade you got left past
seven oh that's a tough that's a toughie
if you do it like first a second or
third no one really kind of knows you're
young enough at seventh oh it [ __ ]
destroyed cuz then you're in the school
with all the eighth graders and they
know that you got left back and you're
still in the seventh yeah so everybody
knows it was funny because I got I got
put in the class with a guy that I
didn't like right off the [ __ ] bat
and once I became his student we got
along and till today we talked on the
phone like this was the way and on the
last day of school I stole his car keys
and his house keys and Trouville a
dumpster and he found that it was me
came to my house we got into an argument
and in September it was like it never
happened
I was going in there expecting the worst
and it's like it never happened
and him and I want a very whatever basis
very touch-and-go for a couple of months
but in those days you went to homeroom
and then the rest of the day you will
alternated classrooms there was for the
classrooms that you would go to history
music whatever so you would only see him
in the beginning for attendance and at
the end or a lunchtime for attendance
and then basketball season came but I
found out he was in the [ __ ] Hall of
Fame in the [ __ ] home of Fayette he's
like one of the only guys from Jersey
he has directed for a glass barrel he
made the most wreath rows in college in
the [ __ ] lead that he liked I think
he still has the racket
nobody's broken his record 73
free-throws in Rio so he went to the ABA
he played from of Miami for idiots they
won under he was too slow for the NBA
you know it's just the [ __ ] team is a
good shoe though so he's sure I I
tormented him to [ __ ] coaches said he
would [ __ ] coaches so I finally showed
up at his house with it and he had a
hoop in front of his house he came down
and he goes all right I can't coach you
guys but I can coach you off record will
do it hit and we did it a few times and
we were like two [ __ ] and we turned
that the whole season around we made the
playoffs
I just became friends and after that so
me getting left back was like a [ __ ]
good move for me because till today I
took him to a premier grudge match
that's how tight I am around he owns a
bar now I reckon thing is not arrogant
yeah man
so how does something good out of
something bad you get something good
yeah yeah I never got left back but I
just you know you cut corners
I remember 10th grade geometry I
couldn't figure that [ __ ] out neither I
still can't yeah I was just like I don't
know why stuck and you don't get angles
I I'm okay with algebra but I just can't
I deny that in chemistry maybe it's
really yeah maybe but I remember when
there was a day of the test I wouldn't
show up because I was I knew I was gonna
fail it so I know I would just not go to
that class I had like four tests that I
didn't take I was gonna fail for the
mark appeared of it because it was just
I was gonna have to go back and take him
at some point I remembered a teacher
goes hey if everyone wants to go up to
my desk and look at the gradebook and
see your grades you can I'm gonna leave
it open so everyone was just walking up
you know like looking at it and she won
out of the room she went like down to
the office or something like that so
when I got up to my gradebook and I
looked I had four empty slots and my
grades I [ __ ] took her pen right
there put 86-84 eighty to ninety one
filled in every grade and past what I
see she had no idea I used to do kinky
[ __ ] like that and then the report card
would come to the house like they'd mail
it to the house so I get the mail first
and you can erase like the number that
they gave you like an F would have liked
a little erased ooh my buddy had this
little eraser and you could trace it and
put like a D or a C or whatever like
that so we check our parents by doing
that yes the mom looked real close yeah
and tells you couldnt tell there was
some professionals there was these two
chicks right by my house they was
[ __ ] clean up your report card jack
you dropped it off he was one our
service how old were they sixteen
fifteen two sisters I see them at my
shows you find the time they would take
your report card dog [ __ ] white it
out make copies they were just geniuses
sand the white out
so you couldn't see it it was crazily
with these [ __ ] freaks as long as you
got it because you today would mail him
so you just knew when they were going
out so you'd get them before your
parents you get that mail that day
that's the way o'clock the mail with you
got at school at 3 o'clock and your
parents we're gonna home to 5 you got
the man give a [ __ ] check that day you
didn't go back to school afterwards
teaching report cards are online now
yeah and well I know that for college
but fer let you in high school and stuff
yeah my boys in first grade so it's
online is that he finished great yeah I
told you boys yeah boy was one old boy
though I got left back to the NASA he
lose the few full time right uh he's
with me like four days a week
ok and then I worked you know I'm home
on him and then you know and then I
gotta work on the weekends what's the
mom do she's called spices like 15
minutes away so he sees with her to rest
it away who's she worked yeah she's uh
does lacrosse stuff that's bacon jersey
lacrosse ya know when I was there I know
no I never heard of it until until of
Duke Lacrosse case when that [ __ ]
woman said this dudes right died any
male either that's a sport I never
[ __ ] heard of it what does that it
was big when I was going to high school
that was like a rich kid sport in I say
[ __ ] I'm still in 1982 I can I feel
there's parts of me that still live in a
world that nobody really understands and
because I just don't [ __ ] with it like I
love Jersey only [ __ ] I look like one
of them Jersey only dark Spanish people
played soccer yeah and then a play away
Saturday afternoons in the park and
their own little corner and [ __ ] soccer
wasn't legalized yet what well that left
Jersey soccer was not across the board
the way this okay you know about Pele
and that was it
I've been played soccer I think you mean
it was illegal it was kind of illegal
because every time you saw people
playing soccer the car will pull over
and go immigration and they will [ __ ]
take off but Sin Cara Lee Park yeah
okay every Sunday they would get
together and play oh it's crazy I never
heard of all this [ __ ] lacrosse I didn't
hear about rugby till I moved to Aspen
no I lived in yeah yeah when I moved to
Aspen I was walking home and then I saw
a bunch of gorillas tackling each other
I was 18 years old and play rugby in
Jersey I went skiing one time in Jersey
I went to the Playboy Resort you
happened wherever the [ __ ] it was way up
there and they used to have midnight
skiing and a cocaine been to my friends
thought it would be a good idea to shoot
out to this place for Midnight's game
and do blow ism there's nothing blown
the world and dummy at the restrain that
[ __ ] call witness I come off and
midnight I went out there and ran back
the [ __ ] and it wasn't skiing like
you get in Colorado this was rocks ice
like I solid [ __ ] if you fell you heard
you were breaking you back there was no
two ways about it
you were breaking your back it was a
Jews attorneys paradise up there you
need money go up there [ __ ] slip and
fall it was so disgusting
it was so [ __ ] cold Jim and then I
wanted to call around I'm like go skiing
I'm like [ __ ] you I did that [ __ ]
already [ __ ] you [ __ ] savages and my
friends like no dogs usually what ski
the dump
you think goes easy snowman literally
and I [ __ ] got on skis and I loved it
I even got a job that gave me a ski pass
and I would ski early in the mornings
because that lived close to the mountain
right so I would ski right off my
[ __ ] back yard I would take level 3
runs of [ __ ] don't home wash my [ __ ]
and go to the video store just like that
Jesus that's perfect like never once
game before never never she have no idea
it's so much fun you kid will love it
you take him for like a small rizzoli
you do a comedy works and that's what
county works is wrapped up taking that
Aspen but take them all offseason want
to know what New England that I went to
listen really small baby echoes even in
Jersey like the Poconos is where like
that sounds out of Jersey they over here
was fake snow they had a pretty lady
let's weapons Healy yeah no reason gonna
[ __ ] Boston with a bunch of [ __ ]
carnival in Boston whoever the [ __ ] it
is he's gonna go to Aspen
he's fine you gonna Aspen during
everyone's you go for a three four-day
or you take ski lessons he takes ski
lessons I tell you what if he's [ __ ]
six you go Jesus Christ this is
beautiful and you'll be trying to
struggle to ski and next thing you look
over to the right and you'll hear like
children's team children's team and
you'll see your boy in a deep tuck with
a helmet on doing dirty miles allow in
your Harlow spot because they're closely
gravity so they could ski the first
[ __ ] today all they had this brand
over and they just snowplow and done
they've done those [ __ ] little kids
[ __ ] savages like you and me we take
a few Falls at first yeah it'll only pop
up our skis are over there you gotta get
up in the one ski on your foot and
walking on board and you're sweating
profusely you put on like a vinyl shirt
that cover you from the snow Joey Diaz
told you to put it on but it's [ __ ]
hot now those things get a hot jack and
if it's not snowing no it's not really
cold
you're basically skiing the [ __ ]
sauna so it's worse for you so my
friends will always go for skiing a lot
put that on to the snowflakes most
acanti it's not a big [ __ ] difference
because when you're just whitening the
call to get you Calder yeah you get cold
you have that sweat underneath yeah can
you put like three four pairs of socks
yeah I was always the theory it's gonna
kitten and your feet sweat I ain't never
had health insurance so that's why I
never did dangerous [ __ ] like that like
when did you get health insurance as a
comic or I think I like 41 was the first
time I got health insurer
insurance till 1998 which put me 35
years old I think I like 2003 or that I
didn't have insurance I didn't give a
[ __ ]
can you really didn't either no you
didn't because what's gonna happen
either you break an arm you go to the
[ __ ] emergency room and then every I
went to like 32 emergency rooms and
there was only one bill on my credit
bureau cuz I did a whole sweep just to
look for what has been on over the years
well cuz if you don't give me a social
security number they can't put it on
your credit report so if you put a fake
social security number down to just
leave that blank and then I'll tell you
to fill it in they'll that won't go on
your credit report like the first time I
went to sag well that first sign would
sag I had a [ __ ] I was out one night
and I had this pain in lad and the next
day I woke up and my buddy said you have
abscess he goes at your point it's right
there you have to go to the hospital
so I was like I have sag insurance I'm
with them for the hospital don't forget
this the first time went down the well
the [ __ ] is now let's see the sign that
I waited saw the chick she gave me this
thing she pierced it they took like an
emergency [ __ ] to tap tremendous they
sent me around the corner all [ __ ] up
from the ether and then about six months
later I got a bill with zero zero zero
it's been paid by sag and a check for
like eighteen dollars for a cab ride
I never got
that's when SAG was saying I don't know
what's going on there
no no I have insurance and I'm sure I
don't know I'm sure it's a win this five
hundred bucks a month I feel [ __ ]
horrible about what that they just
killing people I got sag insurance and
yeah it's it's you have it I don't have
you have to make for a family insurance
you have to make 30 grand a year when
did you become say to that well after it
was after and then the merge would sag
but I've been after sag since like 2002
when I got the crank anchors gig I had a
join and it costs like a grand that join
I've been with them since 2002 and I've
always been on TV shows where I made
enough right basically get free health
insurance that I have to pay a little
but not anymore I have to meet young to
make 30 grand now in sag AFTRA to get a
family health insurance get you and your
family covered so I'm not making that in
that actors to hit on enough TV and and
film work where I'm not getting this is
like the first year I had to pay out of
pocket because when I had that metal
show was on for ten years and that Crank
Yankers and all the other [ __ ] I always
got always covered it so pay like five
hundred sixty bucks a month for my
insurance and then uh my kids would have
on his mom's insurance with to her job
but it basically for a family of four
it's like nineteen thousand dollars in
New Jersey if you don't have insurance
if they spelled nineteen thousand for
you your wife two kids a year 19 grand a
year and that's just to be covered that
doesn't you know it's not you don't get
that much and d/dr balls or you know
chill like that but that's they say what
it is we when I lived down in Florida we
used to [ __ ] these skanks this was in
the 80s my friends were all bands these
metal pans and I would just be hanging
out with them and I'd get this just a
leftovers and if we didn't we're cut we
had no money we'll make a like for like
thirty dollars a day at this like day
job of construction so we didn't have
any money if we caught anything or
something all of a sudden we've got the
leaky dick he's always back in the 80s
you get that [ __ ] we couldn't go to the
doctor because the doctor was like 75
bucks and then the pills like another 40
so we went down there
store got fished tetracycline and took
that cuz I was like a form of penicillin
because we had a fish tank and the fish
we get they so you got to protect
recycling and there's some kind of
infection or whatever it's like that so
we go down at a fish store and just get
it there and just start popping them and
it would go away and they were like four
bucks for like 20 pills it's supposed to
be for fish why sometimes the girl was
really skanky before we even felt
anything we better start popping them
now cuz it's probably gonna be a problem
I'm proud of you you wrote a [ __ ]
book man I thought it was thank you
third whatever hopefully I got a second
law from yeah I brought there's always
like a story about me growing up in
Jersey some crazy [ __ ] we didn't do
construction site or prank calls and
then I go into all like the fashion
social media stuff but the interesting
[ __ ] went probably it was Savage I'm out
there man I didn't know you had it in
you to sit down and put it together
that's a pain a [ __ ] ass you think
you're at home [ __ ] headbangin was in
the high Alec and I had made a little
doing though you were by the desk this
morning I put my kid on the bus who get
up at 7:00 he gets on the bus at 8:00 we
were listening to Sabbath
I had never say die on and then I had
Johnny blade on for him he loved it
that's what we do in the morning no
spongebob Sabbath though spongebob with
that well he likes it but it still but
if we put music on I don't live with
that it's always good morning listen the
Sabbath yeah always to get out of the
house that list a little sad but get
your day started I come anytime what hey
there's a fire
given those deadly every time we hear
there's a [ __ ] fire and it's close by
okay this guy's got a [ __ ] mosey along
like a [ __ ] is that a fire or play
with the fire that's a fire
cotton did you see the documentary on
Showtime the end
Black Sabbath oh yes I did when they
were doing that stuff in the studio yes
a couple days after the last show when
they do changes okay oh man and they do
wicked world in The Wizard like it you
know just Tony there's two four guys in
a studio and singing of this plane -
right there was phenomenal well he broke
out the harmonica
yeah um oh [ __ ] was that great I was
great that was great
Monica huzi huzi do you get him when he
took it out he just like started [ __ ]
around Mike and I knew he was going into
wizard the out it doesn't take a [ __ ]
master mind I was like that's pretty
cool I love changes told me that's a
right song I just know the whole thing
was very uh it's amazing that these guys
are in their 70s don't what they're
doing that's scary
yahzee just turned 69 and u7n tony also
he's a hundred thirty and cocaine Oh
easily
I know like these dogs are three but
he's really 21 and dog he is
same thing with cocaine cocaine runs
your body he did it for 30 [ __ ] years
he's got he's a hundred and eight in
cocaine he is he should be done he's 70
when we were children 70 seemed like you
were dead yeah fifty seemed like such a
number that you could not even imagine
like you're 15 Jesus your [ __ ] hold
you know now I'm [ __ ] 50 I don't feel
that gold I'm tired now that [ __ ]
holes a muddle yeah I don't feel as like
what the illusion I had old people did I
thought this was it being 55 men you
went home at five o'clock you had a
couple shots before you went home you
yelled at your wife you had dinner
you have one of those reclinable chairs
your watch TV baby
do anything you sat there till 10 then
you went to bed that's it that was my
dad yeah that's it plain and simple no
[ __ ] must know
fuss because you're putting the house
together that gives you the right to sit
on that chair for six hours every
[ __ ] night maybe you get up and take
a [ __ ] but your house slippers on
he dinner you get about nine there to
get some cookies beside that that's it
there's no [ __ ] movements really I
don't know I'm up and [ __ ] about all
goddamn day
but then I have friends are my age the
deliverance [ __ ] for [ __ ] fellow
expressed had drivers and I see those
guys on my [ __ ] block a load of [ __ ]
and ragged never do that at this age I'd
be done I get to that [ __ ] two days a
week I do one damn Monday and one day on
Thursday and I'll give me enough
recovery time but to get off those
[ __ ] little stairs with a box
well upstairs knock on somebody's door
I'd be dead ten I don't [ __ ] there
you could do that you hmm
I mean I could but I wouldn't how about
you really think I don't think so I
really imagine us whether your ass would
be walk up and down those stairs your
girlfriend would never eat it I wouldn't
either so if you watch now assholey
right and you look at your girlfriend
sitting my ass how would you would you
love it if she was game you see I'm not
gonna say that might I say never but
right now it doesn't do anything I love
you what about you really grow this
weekend in Austin and she's sucking your
pipe right yeah
pulls up your little stumpy and get
there sure and she sucks dick him then
she licks your ass how what do you do I
think up ice cream and forget a little
bit I mean unless it was just amazing I
don't know I think he's afraid he's
gonna like it
and I mean it could be part of the part
of that well if your girlfriend came to
you tonight said hey let's we should mix
things up right we really should you
know it's getting kind of boring and
stuff and let's you know let's try some
different things take a shower and we'll
just experiment and then Oh next to no
she's eating your ass
I guess maybe but I don't know it still
freaks me out down there you're gonna
love it
you'll be [ __ ] back in nowhere like
you're a cat trying to rub on her way
out look how far how far does this go oh
yeah look at our fingers going up there
no I mean you know maybe they're the
first knuckle first what knuckle maybe
but it's just you know whatever whatever
she does it what's the big deal I don't
think I want anything on my bubble well
it's not what you were sometimes you
know sometimes you got to take the
bullet at least she doesn't have like a
to go down there so that's cool
but if she doesn't but if you met a girl
is pretend all right I'm gonna go Jesus
Christ
definitely I don't think so I know
that's uh I mean when did you guys get
because we guys always cool with that
stuff I don't like butt stuff to be
honest me I was very scared for years
then it happens when I move darling no
big for exactly you don't never know you
never know
so get it together will you slip me I
guess so you know saying let the
practice on this girl
hey were there any woman who uh proper
hole stuff like tweet me in telling them
but like telling why it's like not the
most like I don't like it like tell me
why it's like not gross see your other
you're [ __ ] yeah I'm sure you see what
I got a deal with you
yeah you gotta relax you do a bond here
you take just two bunions put together
technical a dummy you'd be relying
you're gonna get there all right he's
not I'm gonna for years he's been we've
been trying the black chick that was in
the father's face and just to break the
whole patois is for a year I kept
pushing it I had a girl that wanted to
do
he wouldn't do it he had a girl there
was a girl in Denver that sent for him
no she had tie the rat you know there
was just so many things I'll bring him
up neither you gotta get going and I
went through this and it's a tough
subject I don't know what that's all
front of their face listen you're 29
so these are the things I did to do when
I was your age I wish I had the chance
to get a little handsome guy like
yourself on the radio you shave your
head you shave your beard you don't get
22 [ __ ] years old you're going to a
bar with a long jacket on they're gonna
start bringing you home late all these
little noises and farting in my face
no one of these girls won't listen what
happened she's gonna spin around on you
and get into a load side position and
suck your balls what do you think a
[ __ ] month is gonna be in your face
and you gotta take it and sometimes when
you know I'm looking at about 160 lining
you sit man it's right there staring at
you and you're in the bottom and the
legs are down your neck so what do you
do to it
you either sniff it right you take the
ride brother meanwhile in Rome I don't
know Lee you have to use your
imagination just get it together you
slip all right Maya
my ex-wife would never let me eat her
ass I I was [ __ ] she defend me away
and push me away and I finally gave up
after like a year and I I filmed the
comedy special and she saw me do two
shows in a theater and she loved me in
her ass that night I think she was just
like I gotta he just had an unbelievable
night he just filmed the comedy special
you already mean six cameras shoot and
she goes I'm gonna hold school and that
was the first time I ate her ass it's an
old school gonna give you a gift they
say the best move I'll take a good
[ __ ] pause three months later our
marriage is over but I got in there I
got in there and on the night I film the
special if she was there with her family
they all watched all knowing that she
was only yes a family is they go he did
such a you know take him home he's a
saint
are you old school I gotta take it to
the hoop and I was building a home and
give me a [ __ ] store really wouldn't
that was too sweaty shows I did you know
that's really silly you gotta get it
together yeah so that she was a hardware
for I guess I'm just saying it was just
it was a special night
you know they I think of that night more
she that there was some ass eating going
on then I film the comedy special that
meant more to me prior you know that's
how good it is maybe I left you that the
good review I - you know recycle two
stories now not nothing really like that
Jim Norton wrote the foreword and he
wrote about us hooking up with girls
like the whole forwards about that but
you know he's gonna wind up like Trump
there was a whole thing that Trump
hooked up with his porno girls cuz he
just liked it one in one position I was
it that's late that's late you don't
want that getting out there it's getting
out there 20 years ago when he [ __ ]
his porn star he only liked one position
a couple that's if you're gonna be the
same way I he's just kind of positioned
I'm not I'm going all up it like this
yeah you possibly have with you on all
fours that's one of the that's one of
many starting positions but I'm gonna do
it this [ __ ] yeah come on I mean Joe
we would have to get him an eight ball
of coke do all of us stop be drinking
not he might not get [ __ ] till 7:00 in
the morning
these girls are giving it up at [ __ ]
eight o'clock at night that's right to
you you know I spend any money you take
a bunch of polite and don't want to go
[ __ ] yeah like a strange it type
I see how women look at leave all around
the shame they don't go to mall strange
they'll go they go you know what Uncle
Fester would eat the [ __ ] out of my
[ __ ] on say Joe we had to put a
nine-hour shift in with an eight ball of
coke nice to drinkin and then listen in
a Snapple all night and then maybe he
would get it I like eight eight nine in
the morning I'm like alone I did somehow
boys we killed yourself when's the book
come on Jim February 20th beautiful they
can pre-order now and yeah pre-order it
everybody is awful except you what's up
an Amazon and all that stuff and uh yeah
but it's good stuff Philly concerts and
they you talk about
um that's the next one that's the next
one I talked about the scorpions concert
where they scorpions took took the girl
I think I told that story on here I go
to respect him to sea scorpions probably
85 86 I sneak down to the front I get
all the way to the front row I'm in the
front row was general mission I go to
get a beer I see this hot chick and I go
hey I go you know start talking I go you
want to come to the front with me shoes
you can got me opt out go yeah so we
just pushed away I got her all the way
to the front we're in the front row
watching the scorpions she's so excited
she's up there she's a big fan we start
making out thrown a show right scorpions
are on she's grabbed my dick I'm
grabbing her tits
she starts flashing the scorpions in the
front row these big tits this beautiful
blonde chick like 20 there they're
giving me the thumbs up they're like
smiling they're all pointing over and oh
my god I'm grabbing her tits and she's
grabbed my dick and and the scorpions
like what a cool score cool dude he's
letting his girlfriend show her tits
whatever so after the show ends one of
the roadies comes over he goes hey the
Scorpions want you guys to come
backstage like holy [ __ ] we [ __ ] he
walked us all around the side of the
building we get to the door she's
walking she's first she goes through the
[ __ ] bounce it stops on my way goes
no just her I go now this the guy just
said two scorpions what he goes no just
her and her name was Melanie I'll never
forget I'm like Melanie Melanie Melanie
they bowled on me in she never looked
back and I was mad at the scorpions for
like a year that [ __ ] them they stole
my girl but meanwhile who I ate as a
comic I know when I was like single back
when I first started playing down to
Florida so I didn't want dudes backstage
of course why would they want me back
there I was gonna ask him you know who
you know who was that on the blackout
cover and who was singing backup on
[ __ ] some weird song that's what I
were to talk to him about meanwhile
she's flashing at it so why would they
want me there she left me in the dust
didn't even look so that stories in the
book she left you for the band yeah of
course she'd even look back on
sorry or let me see what I could do
maybe I can get you pass now come on ten
minutes if there's no drugs and I had no
I didn't even know it like I had never
fallen over know what none of that [ __ ]
I'd still be mad if I were you
before you go do you know what I hold a
grudge I would introduce some of the guy
[ __ ] with a guitar leathers sure I'll
get oh you know what I'm not matter
anymore I did her ass in a second I
would have done with that night but so
even after shoots with the scorpions
okay sometimes you got to go you know
what I mean they going at all put all
New York City those old-school people's
you know what's on the floor you got to
do what you got to do sometimes you know
it's sticky what do you know you're in a
war so I won't been to a strip club
you're in a war zone
sometimes just use your sneakers stick
to the floor you just on time and just
walk out in your socks look it's not
worth it that's we got a dough you're on
a war zone
why would they jack off on the floor
where's it gonna go on the ceiling
somewhere tastes you you don't have to
shoes you just you're horny you struck
out you were at the Palladium all night
it's 4:00 in the morning you're gonna
[ __ ] booth you watch a movie you jerk
off yeah I'm gonna you're not thinking
about tissues you're not thinking about
where it goes
I got a mob guy that's gonna come in in
like five minutes I know but disgust
it's like that's like an actual lovely
boys about the flu that's disgusting
they saw in your milkshake they care
about the flu I love you Leigh how could
you Jack I'll just like it's a joke Lee
no no no I know you're not saying I'm a
buddy it's true there's a mob guy yeah
so I mean they don't for themselves no
no they just leave it they come on the
fool I'm gonna do step on it and kill it
I brought a girl into booth one time
this hot blonde and we were [ __ ] up
and we're right in one rose boots cuz we
didn't have a hotel room and I was on my
knees eating a [ __ ] in the booth I I
could what am I gonna do at that point
you don't I mean he's my one shot I
don't she's not coming on the train to
Jersey and an hour train ride
and still gonna do what you want in that
moment that's what needed to be done I
applaud your socialness but them then it
makes sense after you got burnt the
first time by the scorpions you tighten
your game up absolutely now when you see
them your [ __ ] hand come from you
hang something to yourself right off the
bat to say [ __ ] ain't gonna happen again
jack and only cost a quarter because you
put a quarter in you get the movie-going
did you even start the movie
yeah why you just all caught her in a
movie plays like four minutes with this
is the place with the booth
yeah the boots like I'm 42nd like shell
World Report I thought you were there
with the girl you started the movie too
yeah cuz we wanted to get her in the
mood - okay wait he's resourceful again
yeah you want like a red bow it's like a
Boy Scout to the closure from some angle
and you wanted to hurt if the get was on
the floor and what an ugly situation it
was what a disgusting place I never
looked at it from this view thing he
said it I got walked him there when I
was 13 14 the first time played hooky
thankfully not knowing what you're
walking into
they could have taken us in the back and
sold us in Spain because the creepiest
people hung out in there oh my god
creepiest I would go in there with six
or seven kids man
oh this is how you didn't give a [ __ ] as
long as you're a dollar bill and you got
changing there that's a tea guy boy I'll
be 18 and I get there you [ __ ] either
you weren't [ __ ] 18 or you were 12
you know anything if it could Dantas I
was just telling that we used to go to
those things we would [ __ ] do like
like we got a joint dipping in
formaldehyde I'd smoke at six or seven
ways and then take a bus into the city
and
down my 42nd Street down there we go it
we meet up on a HUD 7h3 by Port
Authority up there at five o'clock we'd
be roam in the [ __ ] cities you and
Lee would go down Broadway and me
whoever I was will go down Fifth Avenue
and go whoever gets up to her at 78th
Street and you'd have to get up there
all [ __ ] up we do the same thing with
angel dust
we call it THC crystal that was the
longest four hours of your life you
thought like you were in a [ __ ] dream
and you would come up on people and they
talked to you he'd talk to them next
thing you know you were walking around a
corner with them to smoke a joint
it was just [ __ ] surreal it was
surreal man yeah I'm happy those days
I'm gonna happen we never get killed its
formaldehyde tastes like like [ __ ]
chemicals like enas somebody what's
right for love only I'm surprised I
haven't already I think we did it one
way I know we had done them who smoked
at the joint one doesn't think so
always a pleasure having you yeah
absolutely give a website to think you
go to jim Florentine calm there you go
no [ __ ] done and I do a podcast every
week comedy mental midgets so you're on
your own my serious - yeah yeah I do a
show on Ozzy's boneyard every Thursday
I'll do a tribute to Fast Eddie Clarke
this week for Motorhead you're the
original guitar player dies all three of
them are gone now fete filthy animal
tail or Lemmy and Fast Eddie I was a big
Motorhead fan back in the day so he just
passed away last week I saw he pesto it
was pre [ __ ] and he was with fast way
to we start a fast way after left
Motorhead
they sounded just like Zeppelin those
guys you're a [ __ ] Savage Italy you
were coming from you that's it that's an
honour
you're a savage event Billy the Stars
you drink your water you're perfect
you're beautiful
yeah I'm working my way into that my
buddy just got me some gummies okay in
Jersey so I haven't tried them yet he
gave me the other night I'm gonna be
home I don't know I gotta I'm gonna do
very slow cuz I haven't done this time
the gummies are now you'll need to the
lift just taking a little bite of
whatever we're gonna take a little bite
I'll make sure on my home make sure you
have ice cream and then we'll see what
happens oh yeah just in case he comes
out
American cheese yellow boy salami you
know white bread that's what the animal
ice and just let you know
yeah I'm most safe but you got caught
with your pants down what happened
doesn't get what the animal wants then
you eat cookies and [ __ ] turkey bacon
and all this [ __ ] you eat [ __ ]
that's what happens right okay what
would you ask Nick you know what [ __ ]
happens all right unbelievable people
first off when i think jim Florentine
for coming on great comment go again to
jim Florentine Tom get the link to the
book and also get tour dates number two
let's talk about food right now and blue
apron is the leading meal kit delivery
service in the US and well many people
know what we do many don't know about
the types of meals you eat when you cook
with blue apron you're not just having
burgers for dinners you're making short
rib burgers with a hoppy cheddar sauce
on a pretzel bun you're preparing seared
steaks with thyme pan sauce and mashed
potatoes green beans and crispy shallots
all in under 45 minutes and without a
trip to the grocery store you understand
me
listen blue apron delivers fresh pre
proportion ingredients and step-by-step
recipes right to your door
that can be cooked another 45 minutes
the menu changes every week based on
what's in season and is designed by the
blue apron in-house culinary team blue
apron offers 12 new recipes each week
and customers can pick two three or four
recipes based on what fits their
schedule blue apron sense only GMO
ingredients and meat with no added
hormones all right Lee how much did you
enjoy blue apron
loved it I just sent you more codes to
get some more blue apron sent right the
house how easy was to cook it it's it's
super simple they give you a
step-by-step guide and they keep
improving and it gets better every few
months they take you through every step
and they tell you exactly how long it's
gonna take and I give you a card
everything comes to the house to learn
the Italian treasurer open up everything
you know exactly what's in there and let
me tell you something we use it a lot as
a date night ever this girl from get
together and cook together listen a
family eats together stays together as
corny as it [ __ ] sounds and for eight
weeks and then at the end of February
February 26 blue apron is teeming with
whole thirty to bring you delicious
recipes our menu will feature whole
thirty approved recipes each week like
Mexican spice barramundi with avocado
togarashi chicken lettuce cups with
avocado and kale and sweet potato salad
kick your new year with blue apron and
whole thirty which and this is gonna
really break through because he's
supposed to be a little healthier meal
for you but anyway this is what I'm
gonna do for you blue apron is do
something forever listen to this podcast
if your family here you go they're gonna
give all the listeners a $30 off your
first order if you visit blue apron calm
slash Joey again that's blue apron calm
slash Joey let me tell you this week's
menu right just to keep you on born in
you got a whole thirty approved see it
states with warm lemon salsa verde with
roasted broccoli and sweet potatoes can
you imagine cooking that how know you're
gonna cook them a blue apron look at
this one whole dirty approved chicken
and kale are in salad with spicy tahini
dressing if you imagine cooking that bad
you're gonna cook it with blue apron
here you go spicy pork and Korean rice
cakes with baby bok choy or you can meal
one just say bok choy at the bar
wouldn't want to hang out with you this
is the type of savage you are blue apron
is gonna get you into a little let's it
blue apron has a lot of options alright
fried rice the togarashi peanuts it
the best but listen go to blue and
please calm right now get $30 long for
your first order yeah I gave you this
week's menu get $30 off your first order
and free shipping I blew a pin Thomas
last Joey blue apron a better way to
cook number two listen no more stinky
air so Valentine's Day is coming
you want them to lick your ass we just
get a whole segment about the [ __ ]
ligand you're sitting there like a
[ __ ] zombie all your life
you're 29 years old nobody's eating your
ass you know it ain't something wrong
with society it's something wrong with
you maybe you're not confident about
your [ __ ]
you don't have to feel like this anymore
not now the hell - she is around go to
hell - [ __ ] calm and take a look at the
great selection of portable bidets that
you could attach to your [ __ ] toilet
within minutes within minutes you could
change our horizon your [ __ ] will
become a [ __ ] menu selection now for
years you've been like the ugly girl in
the corner hiding your [ __ ] because
you think they're gonna smell the tuna
fish you had for lunch
I never feel superior
again who gives a [ __ ] suck my dick and
call me shorty I was born in 1940 and
while you're getting your [ __ ] steam
clean dip your [ __ ] helmet in there
too
and add some [ __ ] Maluku juice and
watch that [ __ ] thing
listen hello - she's even got a little
towelettes to scrub your [ __ ] Squatch
a touch in case yeah in case you got a
victim over the house and you could uh
you know whatever I'm saying you know
what I'm talking about
listen it's a [ __ ] luxury to have a
bidet and now you can have one like this
BAM boom you can have one oh the hello -
she's not calm right now
and press in church band get tempus
get 10% off your water you understand me
they got a great selection 90 60-day
90-day guarantee Lee and I have had us
for years we're both over 300 pounds
never trying to pound off your [ __ ]
dare you
you're about to 89 no I'm not listen to
me I'm close and what birthdays are
still intact they're still spitting
water if they keep our asses clean
they'll keep your ass is clean
go to hell Toshi calm right now impress
a church band and get 10% off I want to
thank blue apron I want to thank hello
tushy
I want to thank my main man jim
Florentine a fellow Jersey man give him
some love and jim Florentine Don calm
and I'll see you [ __ ] in Austin
and the rest of you guys I'll see you at
the comedy zone next week in Charlotte
North Carolina
bring the [ __ ] penguin suit it's
gonna be cold [ __ ] have a great
weekend stay black this is from my
buddies over in Hudson County put
together a band I wanted to give them
some love take that [ __ ] mealy